à peine remise de la présidentielle
mouvementée du 3 novembre dernier la
géorgie retournent aux urnes ce 5
janvier un scrutin très attendu dans le
pays avec un intérêt qui dépasse les
frontières du pit states de sièges du
sénat aujourd'hui occupé par des
républicains sont remises en jeu
cette élection décidera donc de la
couleur politique du sénat comme le
souligne donald trump
l'enjeu de cette élection c'est le
contrôle du sénat américain et ça veut
vraiment dire le contrôle du pays les
électeurs de géorgie vont décider quel
parti dirige toutes les commissions
écrit chaque élément de la législation
contrôler chaque dollars des
contribuables
le sénat américain une des deux chambres
du congrès et contrôlent et d'une courte
tête par les républicains hillion 50
sièges contre 48 pour les démocrates
le second tour de cette sénatoriales
partielles en géorgie verra notamment
s'affronter
la sénatrice républicaine kay l'île aux
fleurs face aux démocrates raphael
warnock et john o sauf penser au chemin
parcouru en géorgie pensez au chemin
parcouru dans le sud des états unis
c'est l'état le plus compétitif du pays
qui a accueilli deux élections
sénatoriales pour déterminer qui
contrôlera le sénat des états unis
la géorgie a tellement de pouvoir en ce
moment si les républicains gagnent au
moins un siège en géorgie ils resteront
majoritaires pendant les deux premières
années de la présidence de joe biden en
revanche si les démocrates l'emportent
la chambre haute basculera dans le camp
démocrate
avec 50 sièges pour chaque camp c'est la
future vice-présidente kamala harris qui
comme le prévoit la constitution devra
trancher
[Musique]
oignies
tout est en jeu quand il s'agit d'élire
le révérend raphael warnock délire john
sauf
tu dors là délire daniel blackman tout
est en jeu en cas de défaite des
républicains
c'est le congrès tout entier qui
deviendrait démocrates la chambre des
représentants leur étant déjà acquise
joe biden aurait ainsi le champ libre
pour dérouler son programme